This is Jocko podcast number
one 31 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good Evening Echo and good
evening. It is time for some Q and. A.
Yes. Should we banter around for a
while? She would just get started.
Question number one.
I've been somewhat of a pushover for the
majority of my life since listening to
the podcast.
I've been trying to assert myself more.
One thing I can't seem to shake
is constantly being interrupted.
How can I rise above and
overcome this obstacle?
Should I re read the Hashtag,
the Hashtag fellow hardcore
hardcore and there's a little layer in
there cause he put rise above and there.
So I,
so I thought about this because
I would say I don't get interrupted
a lot. Yeah. But I don't,
I think that's kind of the current state
of me and I think there's a reason why
I don't get interrupted a lot.
And it's not because you know
people are going to think,
oh well that's because you're going to
bash people in the head with a club.
That's not the actual answer
of why I don't get interrupted.
So one thing I think is important is,
you've heard me say this before,
the less people talk,
the more people listen.
So when I'm in a group of people that all
want to talk and they all want to talk
over each other and they
want to cut each other off,
you get in that group right
there. I don't talk, I don't talk.
I let them, I sit there, I
listened to him and I plot.
Then I think,
and I put together my thoughts correctly
so that when I do decide to say
something it's going to have impact
and then I wait for the right moment.
Right.
Because if there's people that
are bickering back and forth,
I wait for a lull in the fire
and when that low comes,
then I make my point in a very
direct manner. I might even,
I might even have to wait
until the conversation is
like all but over wait until
they're done with their little
firefight. Get Pip. Yup, Yup, Yup,
Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup, Yup.
And then I'm not talking, they're
done. And what I, when I talk,
you know I'm going to do it.
Since I've been thinking about it,
it's going to be articulated in a
way that I can present my full point.
And so I think that's an effective
way to do things. I think.
I think if you let people speak a bunch,
you let them get it out of their system
and then when you decide to talk,
they don't have anything left to say.
So that's a way to stop getting cut off.
So this is almost like flanking,
right?
This is a flanking the fact that when
people have a bunch to say and they got
all these thoughts in their head
and they want to get them all out,
let them get them out.
Don't try and fight that battle.
They've got a bunch of things they want
to say. Let them say it. Also, as we know,
when you listen to
someone else talk it you,
you now know what their ideas are.
You know what they're thinking.
There's a power and not saying anything
because it allows you to think and it
allows you to hear what
other people think.
And it allows you to hear other people.
So in a conversation you get to hear
other people's counters to what people are
saying and you're not,
you're not having to expend any ammunition
yourself. Someone else is doing it.
You know,
the,
the third or fourth or fifth piece person
in the conversation that's expanding
ammunition and running their mouth to
try and counter some point that someone's
man let them do that.
Because by the way,
then you get to see what
the other counter is.
So I think being assertive
doesn't mean talking more.
I think being assertive
means talking less,
talking at the appropriate times,
monitoring and understanding the firefight
that's happening so that when other
people have expended their ammunition,
you can step in and you can take
your shots in a simple, clear,
concise manner. That's what I
think. Yeah, I think you're right.
I think you built up
this reputation though.
That's an added element to
your specific situation.
When you talk it like you're not
saying fluff, you know you're,
you know when you talk if like something,
well that's a good point.
So if you don't want to get caught off
and 70% of the things that you say aren't
really that impactful and don't
add a lot to the conversation,
well then there's a good chance that when
you open your mouth to start talking,
someone else doesn't think
it's gonna be important.
So they just jump right on top of you.
But if you say less and to your point,
if the things that you say generally
are well thought out and clear and are
going to have impact,
well then we have a good chance that
you're not going to be cut off because
people actually want to hear
what you're going to say. Yeah.
Don't talk just to talk ever. Yeah. See.
And that's a hard, I shouldn't say ever,
but hardly ever.
Yeah,
that's a hard one because it,
and it's not like people are interrupting
you on purpose because you don't have
nothing to sit, you know, like you're
just talking fluff. That's nice.
Not a conscious on purpose thing.
A lot of the times I think anyway,
it doesn't feel like it is. Um, it feels
like it's like subconscious, you know,
like how can someone see fit to actually
follow through with interrupting
somebody if they don't think like,
okay, this isn't quite that important.
At the very least,
the very least what I'm about to
interrupt with is more important.
So some people think that what they're
about to say is really important.
Here's another thing, it's like the
little boy that cried wolf, right? If I,
if I talk and talk and
talk and talk and talk,
I'm taking away the value of each one
of those statements that I make because
I'm making so many statements that not
all of them can have a high level of
value. So w w, w who do you,
who do you pay more attention to?
The person that makes a hundred
statements and are those, okay.
Let's say you want to pay attention to
the person that makes 100 statements.
How much can you pay attention to those
hundred statements? How much do you,
how much do you gather from those
hundred statements? Yeah. Well, it's,
it's a limited amount.
Yeah, it's 1% per statement,
right? What's 1% you
have to fool. He will.
Do you think I make some
statements at the 1% per statement?
If the person says one thing,
how much percent do you pay attention to
that on dad's retinue seven to 100% so
there you go. Yeah, it
makes sense to check.
Good luck with that fellow hardcore kid.
So I guess he'd kind of have,
I mean assuming that you
know, we understand his
situation. It's hard though.
Overall it's kind of like you have
to build a reputation of saying only
important things.
That's a good way w place to start.
Just be quiet and not only like exactly,
exactly what you said, that added thing,
which you kind of actually
may have already said,
but when you sit back and
just listened to them,
it'll cause you to have to say less
because what if you wanted to like,
oh I was going to make this point.
That's the feeling you get when you
want to interrupt. Someone's like, oh,
I want to
wait right now, kind of thing. You will
find out. You just let people talk.
You don't have to make that point.
They know this stuff already.
You know all that. And then you'll find
that that's probably a lot of the time,
you know, so, and by the way,
if I step in to make a point that people
already know how impactful is that
point,
it's very limited impact.
So the more points that you can hear
that you know and that everyone knows and
that you don't have to say
the better off you are.
So when you do make a point and it's
a point that no one really thought of,
how impactful is that port?
The answer is it's very impactful and it
comes way more clear that it might be a
point that no one thought of after you
listen to everyone and talk for however
long. And then it's like, oh wait,
this wasn't covered so I can say this.
I don't have to say all these other
things are they going to interact with or
whatever. Yeah. Just be quiet, right?
Yes. Be Quiet. And in social situations,
for example,
cool
to me. And this is what I kind of started
doing or tried to start doing in social
situations.
You know how like a k I listened to
my wife and her friends talking there.
It's just a boom, boom interrupting
NRA. It's not rude or nothing.
It's just cause they're just talking and
yeah. And that's, that's how they roll.
Yes.
How they roll and to the point where I'm
getting like little mild micro doses of
anxiety because of all the
interruptions. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like they just talk a lot.
That's what it is. Um, anyway, so,
um, I found in social
situations if I feel that,
like if I'm like trying to talk or that
I'm getting interrupted a lot, a lot, man,
in a way, they don't really care
that much about what you have to say.
They have more like they care more
about what they have to say it,
it's a social situation. So yeah,
you might as well just be quiet.
You're adding less value,
interrupting their valuable stuff,
you know so sure would be quiet and you'll
find that they'll want to talk to you
more too if you'd be quiet
and not interrupt them.
You might have to take some heavies
on the interruption front though.
Cause that is kind of annoying if you
pay attention to it. That's what I think.
I see what you're doing.
And now next question.
I saw your Ted Talk.
I like most people have a boss.
If it wasn't the fault of the guys below
you and there are people above you,
shouldn't they take ownership, I. E.
Your commanding officer and then it in
turn his why would ownership only drift
halfway up.
So in an ideal world, ownership goes
up and down the chain of command.
Absolutely.
And that is how problems get solved
because people take ownership of those
problems throughout the chain of command.
Now does the world always work like that?
No, it doesn't. And
that's okay. That's fine.
Because as the boss of what you're the
boss of, you can't make any excuses.
That's the way it happens.
And when an organization
is taking ownership,
when you've got a team where everyone
is taking ownership on that team,
there's absolutely overlap of everyone
taking responsibility for the different
problems. There'll be some overlap or I
could have done this to help out, oh yeah,
and I would have done this better and
now we both solved the same problem.
But it's,
it's redundant but good because now
we've got two people addressing their
problem.
So that's not a bad thing.
So when people are taking ownership
up and down the chain of command,
the problems are getting not just,
not just solved by one angle,
but by multiple different angles of
everyone that's taking ownership of that
problem.
When the blue on blue happened in
that I talked about extreme ownership,
that was in the Ted talk,
and I talk about this,
like my guys took ownership of
what they did wrong as well.
The guy that shot the, the
Iraqi soldier, the radium,
and took ownership of the fact that
he didn't pass a word quick enough.
The element leader took ownership of
the fact that the Iraqis had gotten away
from him.
They all owned their little pieces.
And of course I owned it as well.
And when I took ownership of everything,
it wasn't like those guys then said,
oh okay, well then I'm absolved and I
don't have to change anything. No, no, no.
Those guys still realized that they made
some mistakes and some things that they
need to clean up.
So I took ownership of the same thing.
They were taking ownership and guess what?
Then again,
it was a redundant that we were
all trying to solve the problems.
Now this is the opposite. This doesn't
happen when you start blaming people.
Everyone makes excuses.
That's just the way it works.
So I think that that's what you have to
think about. So it was, so like I said,
ideally when a leader takes ownership,
so do the people up and
down the chain of command,
they also take ownership of the
problems that need. If they do,
that's great and the leader can then
monitor what those people up and down the
chain of command do to fix the problem.
And if they fix the problems,
then that's great. That's the way it
works. And if they don't fix the problems,
then that's when the leader has to own
it up and down the chain of command and
still be responsible and take
ownership of fixing the problem.
So
the other piece of this,
I guess is that
that's why extreme ownership works.
It works because people that
don't take ownership, again,
up or down the chain of command,
they will be, they will,
they will end up being overrun
by the people that take ownership.
It might not happen immediately,
but eventually the people that make
excuses will be overrun by the people that
take ownership. That's the way it
works. And by the way, then I, again,
I talked about this in the Ted talk when
that whole thing happened and I took
ownership of it, my boss then
trusted me more, not less.
And that's the way,
that's what happens.
You end up increasing your trust.
So,
so take ownership. If your boss
takes ownership too, that's awesome.
That's awesome.
That means you've got multiple
people trying to solve the problem,
which is good for the team.
You guys get asked this a lot.
For some reason life gets asked this a lot
where
it's a lot,
a lot like almost every single time I see
life in a question answering situation.
He's, they say, what do I do?
Or what happens when my boss isn't taking
over ownership or what do I do when my
whatever isn't taking ownership.
The question is ultimately what do I do
when the other guy isn't taking on and
shit.
Right.
And see how you're smiling right now
because like we all get so obvious,
you know,
essentially that's what this is.
I mean he's not in the
scenario so it's not, you know,
but and how you guys always
say it's like big wall.
The thing is extreme ownership isn't about
the other guy taking ownership or not
taking on a ship. It's about everything
you can personally do to take ownership.
That's it. It stops right
there. No, just like you said,
if everyone else was taking ownership,
which will happen cause it's kind of this
weird contagious kind of thing. Yeah.
And, and I don't want to
throw it out there like, Oh,
if I take ownership then
everyone's automatically check on.
Is that doesn't happen cause
there'll be none of those that don't,
there's some people that are not
looking to take ownership. And again,
those are the people that will
eventually get overwhelmed. Yes.
Because who do you want working for you?
The guy that says,
well this wasn't my fault,
it wasn't,
but someone else do you want that guy
working for you because that person not
going to change.
They're going to do anything different.
They're not going to
get that problem solved.
You want the person working for you that
says, you know what? This is my fault.
This is what I'm gonna do to fix
it. Here we go. Yeah, you go, okay,
well I'll let you continue
to do your job and,
and I want you to continue to do job.
And by the way,
when a promotion opportunity comes up,
guest who I'm promoting,
the guy that makes a bunch of excuses
and blames other people or the guy that
takes ownership and get his
problem solved, you, there
you go. It's a no brainer.
And I think as people see
that in an organization,
the majority of people now this,
I will say the majority of people,
they will also
take ownership. There will be a
minority of people that go, oh,
I'm going to slough off and I'm
going to keep blaming other people.
And in their minds they think they
look good. Right. In my mind when I go,
it was my fault. It was echo's fault.
I think I saved myself from the blame.
What I really did was look like an excuse
making little baby and I don't want to
promote me because I knew it wasn't my
fault. Oh, the podcast and com I was ma,
it wasn't my fault as the echo's fault.
Yeah. Oh really? Okay, well let's,
let's think about that.
Do you want who's or who's responsible?
I'm shirking responsibility and
laying it on some other person.
I don't want that person working
for me. No. So that's why it works.
Yeah. And I was scared of it.
People are scared that, well,
I take the blame.
I'm going to look bad.
Don't you look bad when you don't take
the blame. That's when you look bad? Yeah,
pretty much.
Anytime in one way or another.
Pretty much anytime you look at other
people and be like, Hey, what about them?
You know, in this extreme
ownership situation like the,
it's like it goes against the very nature
is extreme ownership too. To ask like,
Hey, what about them? Why didn't they
take responsibility? Just like, I mean,
back to the question,
it's kind of like just to kind of get
a handle on understanding what extreme
ownership is. If you start to
incorporate, hey, what about them? Hey,
what about the higher ups? Why should
the ownership stop at you? Well,
here's the thing. It doesn't begin.
It begins and stops, stops at me.
That's 100% of what it is now.
Other people,
I mean if I can step out of my
own situation of extreme engine,
just kind of evaluate other people when
they see you or feel you or see you
taking ownership of stuff.
I think it tends to be
contagious like no, absolutely.
That's what I just said. The majority
of people when you take ownership,
when I take ownership of something,
if I go echo, you know what,
this isn't my fault that the podcast
didn't come out and whatever,
this is my fault that we didn't get
this done. You're tendency isn't to go,
oh cool, it's [inaudible] fault. Yeah, I
agree with you two for no, and you'd go,
no man, I should've done this or I
should've done that. And now, once again,
we're both trying to solve the problem.
That's the way it usually ends up. Yeah.
Real interesting. How like, oh, Jamie,
I, you know, email with Jamie, Jamie,
Ashland Fun. Uh, and she'll like,
I'll make some mistake, you know,
on the spelling of something, on some
video on and know something and she'll,
she's real good at taking ownership and
she's like, aw, you know, I should've,
you know, whatever, whatever. And
to the point, sometimes it's like,
I see what you're doing. And it's true.
It's like any feeling of like, oh,
oh, I shouldn't, you know,
excuse making or whatever.
Any feeling of that gun when someone
is like, oh no, no, no, it's my fault.
I should have caught that. And what do
you mean you should have caught that?
I should've caught that. I made the video
kind of thing kind of thing. But man,
it works.
So like it's real contagious.
I think even people who are just
naturally defensive, you know, you know,
cause people were different, you know?
I think over time they tend to be when,
when they kind of build this kind of,
when everyone builds a reputation of
not blaming, it's like they, they,
they let that natural guard down and they
look over time, you know, even if they,
at first they don't want to check.
Next question,
what are some ways to get out of a Rut?
In Jujitsu were just
talking about this off air.
I always get caught in the same spot,
cross side and can't move.
What should I do?
This is a brutal answer but the truth.
Sure.
If you have a hard time in a certain
position, start there every time.
Start with the person across the,
across the side until you get used to it.
And then on top of starting there and
you start working your techniques,
learn some new escapes. Cause whatever
you're doing right now isn't working.
So learn some new excuse escapes.
Now this doesn't mean that
you need to learn 47 escapes,
but if you've got your one go
to escape and it's not working,
does it actually there's a pretty good
chance if you only know one escape from
something, it's not gonna work
cause one escape. Then the guests,
what the person has to defend
one thing and so they stop it.
So learn,
you know,
three escapes total,
maybe four escapes total and these are
escapes that must be escaped that kind of
chained together,
which most of the time they do.
So you learn and you know you can ask,
you can ask,
obviously you can ask your instructor,
you can ask some of the other
students that that you see get out.
How did you do that?
You can even go look at Youtube and Google
Cross side escapes and get some good
ideas from there.
And then you're going to have to take
risks while you try your new escapes in.
You can drill them of course,
but then eventually you're gonna have
to try and live because when you do
something in a drill is not the
same as doing it live it, it's,
there are adjustments that need to be
made and things that you need to figure
out and you're not going to be successful
the first hundred times or 50 times or
28 times or 420 times
that you try something.
There's a lot of little things you got
to figure out and you're going to get
caught in some of those times.
You're going to try something and
you're gonna get caught. So take risks
and try your escapes.
Another point,
and I've probably talked
about this before,
specifically cross side,
don't wait until the person settles
in before you started your escape.
And this is true with anything,
right? This is true with life.
Don't wait until your,
if you see a bad position coming,
don't wait until the position.
Don't wait until the bad thing
actually fully happens to, you know,
start to defend it before
it settles in on you.
You get a bad scenario
coming down the line,
start to aggressively
counter that bad thing, what,
whatever it is before
it actually gets you.
And if you can do that,
then you will be,
I guarantee that that's,
that's a lot of the problem right there.
Cause cause cause getting out of a cross
side is a really hard position to get
out of it.
I don't care who you are.
I have a hard time when dean gets across
side on me and it is hard to get out.
Like I mean it, it's really
hard to get out. Yeah.
So what does that mean? Yeah.
That's a dominant position.
And that's the last thing is like you
have to take some risks to get out.
Sometimes you've got to break the rules
to get out. You got to do something.
You got to offer up a possible submission
to them that you know is coming.
You know, there's some things
that you can do like that. But um,
escaping before the situation has
occurred to you is a very positive thing.
You could do that with anything like you.
You're in a relationship,
you see something bad coming down,
you see a human being you're in a
relationship with and you see that the
relationship is going in a bad direction.
If you try and either fix it or
end it before the thing goes sideways,
that's the smart thing to do.
Yeah,
don't wait until everything's a disaster.
You've got to go and get the
restraining order or whatever. Right?
You're calling the cops
because you've got someone
that's acting irrational.
Don't wait until that moment.
Solve the problem as early as
possible is the point. Yeah,
so that's how you get
out of that little rut.
Yeah. That's what you said in
the beginning of the start,
in that bad situation that that's a huge,
and I don't,
I don't know if all academies do this,
but I mean Dean has always done this
where before you do open matter that live
rolling and whatever,
like right before that there was a
part where it's essentially situational
training. You know, you
go start side control,
we're going to go for two minutes or
a minute, half of whatever, a one,
nine in top and bottom obviously.
And if you get outreach.
Exactly right. Yeah. The,
you know,
the guy,
the top guy is trying to submit the
bottom guy and the bottom guys trying to
escape. If the bottom guy escapes,
you start all over. Yeah. That's it.
And the other point to that is if you get
submitted, doesn't count. Exactly. Right?
Yeah, of course. Yeah. I'm
trying new things. I'm taking
rest. So I expect you, I,
I actually expect that you're
going to get submitted. Yeah.
Because you're trying new things. If
you, in fact, if you don't get submitted,
you fail because you
didn't try something new.
Yeah. That's not what that drills for it.
And you can feel it too, you know, like,
okay, sure the guy tapped me out.
You don't want them to tap you out,
but you're there to escape.
That's it. You know,
so it's not about like winning this
match or losing this round or whatever.
You know, you're, and then you get so
familiar with being inside control.
So when you do go live
role, you're like, oh,
I'm familiar because I've done this
situation with drill who full speed by
though it's a full speed drill and yeah,
you're just so familiar with
that position. So not only
are you more comfortable,
you know those different
escapes that you've learned,
you don't earlier that day or whatever.
Whenever you learn them and then,
then you can execute him way better. Get
comfortable being uncomfortable. Yeah.
But that helps them. That helps
so much those, those situational
sparring, straight holes.
Next question, Jocko.
There are no bad teams,
only bad leaders.
Do you think there are exceptions to this?
If so,
how do you know you're
apart of the exception?
That is a quote from the book,
extreme ownership written by myself and
my brother Leif Babin and it has a quote
that I don't want to say we stole,
but we stole.
We appropriated from David
Hackworth who said there's no bad.
I think you said no bad officers,
no bad units,
only bad officers and Napoleon
who said there's no bad regiments,
only bad kernels. And we said there's
no bad teams, only bad leaders.
And the question is,
is there an exception to this?
And how do you know if you're part of
the exception? Well, actually there is.
There's a big exception to this and the
exception is that there are bad leaders
with good teams. That is
true. That can happen.
Sometimes you get a bad leader that
is running a really, really good team.
So that's an exception to,
I guess it's an except from this world.
Maybe that's the way I took it.
Uh,
so you get a team that's so good
that they just continue to perform,
even though they have a horrible leader,
they perform despite their bad leader.
Gotcha.
Now what this doesn't,
this does not prove you don't,
I would say leadership is the
most important on the battlefield.
This doesn't disprove that statement.
You'd think maybe it does because oh well
you got a bad leader and you've got a
good team. Then maybe leadership
isn't that important. That's wrong.
Actually what it proves is that leadership
can come from any level inside the
organization.
That's what improves and it proves that
because I've seen that over and over
again and when I was running the
training for the seal platoons,
eventually I didn't care where the
leadership in the platoon was because I
realized that it was a real,
it was a real hard thing to hope for
that you had the person that was in the
leadership positions like
a platoon commander or the
platoon chief to to assume
or to figure that they were going to be
the leader that you wanted them to be
was a big assumption to make. And so what
I realized after training for awhile,
it was like even though I wanted the
leaders to be those senior guys who were
supposed to be taking leadership,
eventually I realized as I didn't
care where that leadership came from,
as long as there was a
couple of good leaders,
you would end up with a good seal
platoon in a platoon would be on track.
Now, maybe the question is
what this person is hinting at,
the exception being, is there an
exception that if there is a bad team,
maybe that team is just so filled with
bad people that they can't get the job
done it.
That's the kind of,
except he's talking about or
failing because the team is so bad,
even though the leader is good,
even though the leaders good,
but the team is so bad that that's an
exception to the rule. Well, guess what?
Yeah,
who's responsible for
the people on the team?
Who's responsible training the people
on the team so that they can get good at
their job and they can perform
with excellence or who's
in charge of getting rid
of the people that are subpar so that the
team steps up their performance? Well,
they answered all those
questions is the leader.
So if you're on a bad team
and you're leading the team,
it's your fault and there's no
exceptions to that. Yeah. Zero.
Yeah. I'm over here trying to think of
the exception, but just what you said,
it's like kind of,
yeah. Kind of negate it.
Hey this, this, let's take a real,
a real simple example of like
a sports team, right? Oh,
this sports team got dealt a bad hand
and now the people on the team, well,
what are you going to do? You're going
to train those people who's responsible?
I'm not saying you're going to
per start performing right now,
but you can get on the trajectory
will, you'll be good eventually. Now,
if you just blame, hey, I got
a bad team, well guess what?
Then you don't put an effort.
Guess what?
You're going to continue to be a
loser of the exception. My teammate,
my team is just so bad.
Train your people.
I'm not saying you're a miracle worker.
I'm not saying you can.
You can take people that don't have
any skills and instantly through your
leadership turned them
into incredible performers.
Know that that's not going to
happen, but guess what? As a leader,
you've got and you bring people
into your team that are good. Go.
You do train the people that you do have
up to the best of their abilities and
the people that can't perform the way
they need to perform, you get rid of him.
Yeah.
That's it.
No real exceptions other than, yeah, you
can have a good team with bad leaders.
Yeah. If only because there's a good
leader somewhere in there. You know,
the exception thing, I think
it's healthy, in my opinion,
none of this and most other things where
if if I or we start thinking that we're
the exception so we don't
have to put in like, I dunno,
like the work or whatever. Not necessarily
work with the, you know, how like, okay,
we'll take this and no bad teams, only
bad leaders, leaders. Ah, you know,
if I say I might be the exception
to this because my team is so bad,
it's kind of like just
finished using them yet. Right.
You kind of did a little
cop out there kind of thing.
It bottom line is if you don't
take ownership of what's going on,
then you're not going to perform well.
If you just blame your genetics,
then that means,
okay,
well then I'm not going to get any kind
of shape whatsoever. Then guess what?
Guess what kind of shape you're being
junk, substandard, substandard. Yup.
Jocko leadership is knowing when to cut
someone loose that can't perform in a
team.
But do you have any techniques for trying
to help people who lack common sense
get better in the name of just trying
to make the world a better place?
Obviously without being a jerk.
My, my common answer in situations
like this and you've heard it before,
is to pick, put them in
charge of something, right?
You've got someone that's,
that's doesn't have a lot of common sense.
Pick something that's maybe just outside
their level of competency and put them
in charge of it.
Something that doesn't
put too much at risk.
So you can give them some room to make
some decisions and some mistakes without
doing too much damage.
And then you coach them,
you monitor them and you coach them
and you,
you coach them not just
on what decision to make,
but more important how
to make that decision.
So if you think about what common
sense is, if you break it down, right,
if you break down what common sense is
common says he's like a blanket term that
we don't really relate it
to what it really means,
but it's a blanket term that covers a
person's sort of natural ability to make
good decisions. That's what, that's what
common sense essentially is. Sure. Right?
Because you don't look at someone,
someone makes a bad decision and you
say that person has no common sense.
Someone makes a good decision or
continually makes good decisions.
Going back to that person's got
a lot of a lot of common sense.
So what we're really talking about
is their ability to make decisions.
Hmm.
So when you're trying to help
someone increased their common sense,
what you're really trying to do is
improve their decision making process.
So some things to look at when it
comes to improving your decision making
process. Number One, learn how
to step back and detach. That's,
that's number one.
You can't make good decisions when you're
all embroiled in the, in the gun fight.
Learn how to analyze and assess and
create different courses of action.
Some people only see you one way and
when you only see one way and you can't
detach,
you never opened up your mind to see
that there could possibly be other ways.
You have to in order to have good
common sense slash make good decisions.
You have to understand how to look at
and understand what the consequences of
your actions are going to be and that
includes second and third order effects
because a lot of times when people,
oh that guy has no common sense cause
they do something that to them make sense
at that moment they don't understand
what the consequences are.
They don't understand the second third
order affects and so it ends up being a
bad decision and we just throw out like,
oh that guy's got no common sense
to make a good decision.
You have to know how to mitigate risk.
That's also very important
to make a good decision.
You have to understand what your assets
are and what kind of resources you have.
Even on a simple decision,
even on a quote,
common sense decision,
you have to understand what you have
at hand to help you execute whatever
decision you make. You have to, this
is a big one, you have to learn.
If you want to make good decisions,
you have to understand that you're going
to make assumptions and you have to
analyze those assumptions and see which
ones make sense to make and which ones
are not sensible to make cause obviously,
and there's that old,
there's that old saying about assumptions.
Don't assume because it makes
an ass out of you and me.
That's a pretty realistic saying.
It's a pretty good saying to keep
in the back of your mind if you make
assumptions on things.
However, that being said,
if you make no assumptions,
well then you can never move forward on
most things because you got assume like,
okay,
most of the time this is probably what's
going to happen and you can go forward
with that. So let's go. You know,
the list goes on and and
in on.
And what you need to do is as you
give these people a little bit of
room and a little bit of responsibility
and a little bit of decision making in
their life like you could
do with your kids, right?
You give your kids the opportunity
to make a decision and,
and if they make a bad decision and
all you do is smack them do without
explaining to them the process,
the decision making process,
which is where that decision came from,
then they're never going to gain more
common sense. And you know, when you,
when you think about the list,
I think detachment is actually
the most important thing.
And I think what happens to people that
don't have common sense, they, they,
they actually don't have the ability
at that time because they haven't been
trained properly to see things
from an outside perspective. Yeah.
Have you ever noticed when somebody does
something that's completely lack the
complete lack of common sense
when you raise the point to them,
they're always kind of like astonished
that like they don't even get why what
they did was dumb.
They just think that that's just how
it was going to be and they don't even
understand that what they did was dumb.
Yeah,
and sometimes you have to actually
explain to people that they're so,
they're so embedded in their
decision making process,
they can't see it from an
external perspective so they
don't even understand how
dumb their decision was.
Yeah.
If you can get them some
level of detachment,
then you're moving them
in the right direction.
You're improving their
common sense and yes,
when you're doing that to your credit you
are actually making the world a better
place
and you kind of said this, they knew
it, but you give them experience.
You know like when you let them like
make sure decisions again because really
that's really what common sense is, right?
If you have or don't have common sense,
it's like if you have a lot of experience,
common sense is like you're a little bit
more in touch with it than someone with
very little experience. So let's say,
I mean it's culturally we'll say.
So in Hawaii I went takes off their
shoes when they go in the house.
This is just how, and uh, you know,
in the mainland it's not like that.
So if I've never been to Hawaii, I've
no experience in Hawaii, but you know,
in the, in the, I live in
the mainland the whole time.
But if I don't have any access to the
Hawaii culture, whatever, I go to Hawaii,
I'm going leave my shoes on.
You know, it's like common sense, man,
you take off your shoes if you've only
lived in Hawaii the whole time right now.
So you could argue, hey, all you
gotta do is look around and see.
But I don't,
I'm not trained to look around to see
what everyone's wearing it not wearing,
you know, like bell. So that's
weird. Do you ever notice it?
I would say once a month at the gym,
someone walks on the mat with Jews on
like just not even when it's literally
stepping over a big pile or line of shoes
of flip flops and choose to get on the
map and they're just no factor.
They're just stepping over with their
street shoes on. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
That's the exact, you would think
common sense would tell you, hey,
it looks like every single person,
there's 28 people on the Mat.
None of them are wearing shoes,
and I'm stepping over. You'd think,
but that's a person that doesn't
have common sense. Right.
So what you have to do
with a person like that,
and when you see someone that
does that kind of thing, you know,
let's say your kid did that, you'd
say, hey, instead of just going, hey,
take off your shoes. You know, you
go, hey, before you do something,
look around at the environment. Take
a look around. What do you see? Yeah.
You see all these people on the mat and
none of them wearing shoes and you look
right in front of your feet and there's
all these shoes off the mat that
probably indicates that you
should take off your shoes.
That should be a good
decision. It should be, but,
and the but now you're going into yet
another different type of experience.
Like if you're in in scenarios often
where you were looking around and seeing
what other people are doing and
wearing like and all this stuff.
If you're constantly in situations
in situations like that,
that will become more part of your
common sense. Right. So it's like to say,
I mean there are plenty
of people who in Britain,
normal everyday life
have normal common sense.
Like everyone else who
would wear shoes on the mat,
they just simply would cause they don't,
hey these guys are training,
they're not going to wear
shoes while they're training.
So they took off their shoes.
I'm not training,
I'm just going to go talk
to this guy over here. Boom.
I'm rolling with the shoes on the mat.
Just like, oh, I've never been away.
You know I'm going to go into this house
there. They live here. They didn't.
Maybe he just got out of bed.
Maybe they just want to be comfortable
because they got out of work.
I don't know.
I don't if it doesn't go through the
thought process of my common sense,
common sense is if I don't have to take
off my shoes for something specific I'm
not going to do it. That's
just how, that's just my
comment, experience, you know?
So the common sense is kind
of a situational thing.
You know it's not just cut and dry.
He has commonsense versus not.
So you put them in more experience
that's common to the group. Oh Man.
It's common sense goes up. Fair
enough. I think so. I think so.
Next question.
I have been told by employees
that I'm cold and non engaging.
My peers say I charge hell with a bucket
of water and sometimes get to stop or
sometimes forget to stop
and fill the bucket.
In military training we all went through
the mental part and in battle some
won't engage properly.
I treat my business the same,
the same way as I fought in a firefight
and my mind was clear, focused on the
objective and being aggressive. Always.
Why should my business be any different?
Delegate and don't quit until you
accomplish the goal. Is this wrong?
So let's start with
cold and non unengaging.
I get that people have different levels
of emotional responsiveness. I get that.
I'm probably a little bit on the low
end of that in terms of being super
emotionally responsive.
Agree.
I don't really get mad.
I don't usually get frustrated,
but at the same time as a leader,
you have to show some emotion.
If you show no emotion at all, then
you're on a person. You're a robot,
and robots don't really
connect with people.
And so you don't forming
new relationships.
And if you don't form good relationships,
you're not going to have a good
leadership connection with your team.
That's the way it is. So you
got to show some emotions. You,
you don't need to get all
wild. And in fact, as a leader,
your emotions should be controlled.
They should be. You know,
if a normal person's emotions go from
a one to 10 a leader should be like,
you know, at three, maybe four.
And he shouldn't go beyond that.
And I've talked about this
before. If, if someone,
if my team's getting all
emotional and I'm just all cold,
I actually disconnect from my team and
all of a sudden they're looking at me
like I'm not one of them. Yeah, yeah. It
doesn't even care. Same thing with your,
with your spouse,
if you or your spouse's all mad
about something and you're like, hey,
just calm down, that's going
to be a problem. You have to,
you have to give them some emotions back.
So
show some emotions. As a leader,
you might even have to, you know,
manufacturing that just a little bit
too to let them see that you care.
You've got to do that with
your kids sometimes, you know,
because your kid is doing something
that you know they shouldn't be doing,
but it's kind of funny and
it's hard to get mad at you,
but you realize if you don't get mad
and this, this behavior escalates. Yeah.
Then that's problematic.
Like are you kind of fired up
when your kid does something,
climbs up on a wall and is balancing,
you know, eight feet in the air? Well,
if they fall and crack their head,
that's gonna be a problem. Yeah.
It at the same time you
think it's kind of cool,
but you have to reinforce safety.
Yeah.
And so you got to be like a little
bit angry at them, right? Hey, hey,
I told you not to do the right kid
running in the road or whatever.
You gotta you gotta reinforce
stuff. So it's, uh, you,
you actually have to show
some level of emotions. Now,
as far as the other part of the question
is aggression and never quitting.
Is that wrong? Well,
you know, quite frankly,
yes.
Yes. It can be very wrong. Of course,
much of what the statement is.
It makes sense,
right? Be Aggressive. Don't
quit. Focus on the objective.
Charge into hell with a vengeance.
Right? We all like to hear that. Right.
That reflects a great attitude.
I think everyone would expect me and
they would actually hear me say those
things the same exact thing.
They want to be aggressive.
We're never going to quit.
We're going to take that objective no
matter what you would hear me say that,
but at the same time we have to
remember that there are dichotomies in
leadership,
right?
And taking what is a normally what is
normally a good attitude to an absolute
extreme without any balance at all.
That will turn into a problem.
So it sounds like this
individual is aggressive,
which is a very positive trait,
but it sounds like perhaps there are
times when this individual might be too
aggressive.
Now most people don't want to hear that
and then they don't think they're going
to hear that for me.
Right.
You almost think when somebody
asks me a question like this,
you almost think in their back
of their mind they're going,
you know what Jack was going to tell me
and I'm going to go even harder. Yeah.
Right.
Reinforcement from Jocko about
how being aggressive is awesome,
but here's the reality. And especially
if you throw like the firefight thing,
like Jack was definitely gonna be on
board with me now. But guess what?
Here's the reality.
If you're in a firefight and the enemy
is in an elevated bunker to position
across open ground and you just
keep attacking it with your platoon,
what's going to happen?
I'll tell you what's going to happen.
You're all going to die.
That's what's going to happen.
So you're all fired up, you're all
aggressive, you're never going to quit,
and you're all going to die.
Does that help us?
Does that help us achieve our overall
strategic objective? The answer is no.
If you pull back for a minute,
if you detach from a moment mentally
and possibly physically as well,
you will likely see that
there's a better approach. Oh,
how about we call for fire support? Hmm?
How would we put down some cupboard,
lay down some suppressive fire and move
around to the flank of the bunkered
position?
There's a bunch of different ways that
you can get this done in a much more
survivable way. Hmm. But the fact is,
if you're always aggressive and your
mindset is I am not going to quit,
then you won't see those other solutions
and yes, that is problematic. Yes,
that is wrong. And it's the same
thing in dealing with people.
If,
if
people don't respond to your leadership
and your reaction to that is just to get
more and more aggressive with them.
Okay. They aren't likely to come around.
In fact,
they are likely to either become
hostile towards you because you're being
aggressive towards them or the break.
Yeah.
Which each one of those is
problematic. Bad, bad results.
Either my team becomes hostile
towards me or I break my team.
Either way it's bad.
So being aggressive all
the time, no, not good.
And same thing. Same thing. Could
be like I default aggressive. Right?
I literally teach people to be that way,
but if you go too far with it,
you'll end up in a bad situation. Same
thing with don't quit. Right. Of course.
Of course. Don't quit. Great attitudes
might attitudes. I'm never going to quit.
I want everyone on my team to have
that attitude. I have that attitude.
That's like the, the [inaudible]
in the seal teams. Don't quit,
never quit.
But you have to be very,
very careful that you don't confuse,
don't quit
with,
don't try any other solutions or don't
deviate from the original plan no matter
what. Yeah, yeah. Hey, I'm not quitting.
I'm just gonna keep doing the
same thing over and over again.
I'm going to keep going forward at the
same plan. The plan isn't working. Yeah.
Okay. But I'm not a quitter. I'm
just gonna keep doing the same plant.
That's not good.
Don't quit means you don't give up.
It actually don't.
Quit actually means try different
solutions. If one of them isn't working,
don't quit means keep an open mind.
Don't quit means you don't quit thinking.
Don't think, don't quit
thinking and then don't quit me.
And to continue to keep thinking and
keep addressing a problem and keep
attacking the problem until
you do accomplish the mission.
But you do that through
multiple different avenues,
not the same avenue the whole time.
That's how you lead.
That's how you get aggressive.
That's how you actually never quit.
And by the way, that is how you,
when,
yeah, that morale thing. Remember you
were talking about morale actually
where you know how like some
bosses it'll be like, hey,
I'm not here to make you feel good or
I'm not here to make friends or whatever.
You know,
and sometimes like behavior or whatever,
thinking like that can lead to behave
with that makes people not want to work
for you or not feel good about the job.
Like I'm not happy about it.
What's the use of making someone do the
job if they don't feel good about doing
it? You don't like to let the morale
is down. I used to think a wall morale.
Like people need to just toughen up.
You know, like freaking morality. You,
you don't just not do something just
because you're not feeling good that day
kind of kind of thing. I
thought that too, but man,
if you have a group of people who
they all don't want to do it by,
they're not going to do it. It's problem.
At the end of the day they're going to
do it. Well, they might do that.
One thing that day. Yeah. I mean,
every time you can break down for sure.
Yeah.
You're not leading them in the
in the right direction. Yeah.
You can look forcing people to do things
when you're in a position of authority,
you can do that. Yeah. That works.
That's functional. That's a thing.
It'll work a little bit. Yeah. Right.
But over time will you end up with a team
that really will perform well and will
continue to drive when they
hit obstacles? No, you won't.
You'll end up with a team that's doing
what they're being told to do out of fear,
and that team is going to get beat by
the team that is doing it because they
want to do it.
Yeah. Yeah. So if it's
like, you know, the guy who,
you know, they, I don't think that
my boss cares about me. In fact,
I think that he kind of doesn't
care about me. That's what I think.
You're not going to do a lot of
extra effort to support your boss.
I'm sure we'll want to.
Next question, Jocko,
do you talk about bill or you talk about
building relationships a lot at work,
even when people whom you might not
like even with people who mean you don't
like, have you always been this
way or did you also feel difficult?
Also feel difficulty in wanting to
build relationships with those people?
If the ladder,
what are the things that help you to
actually want to build relationships with
them?
So,
or when I was a young seal,
I was pretty typical young seal,
pretty typical young man. Sure.
Meaning I thought I was invincible.
I thought I could beat everyone in a
fight because I didn't know Jujitsu.
So you just think you're just
going to win but that you're wrong.
I thought I knew everything,
of course,
and I thought I was smarter than
everyone else. Kinda typical.
Sometimes I would rub people the wrong way
and the people that I would rub the
wrong way where especially people that I
thought thought we're not squared
away in the chain of command.
So if you weren't square,
if you,
if you were my boss and I didn't
think you were squared away. Yeah,
I was going to rub you the wrong way
because I was going to be slightly
offensive. As a matter of
fact, I got an evaluation.
It's one of the first evaluations
that I got when I got to a seal team.
And back in the day, yeah, you'd get,
you were rated 4.0 was the highest you
could get and it would go all the way
down to whatever like one.
But at this time they basically, everyone
got four o and everything, right?
You basically got four o and everything
and like you'd have to mess up,
you have to mess up to get
deviate from the forest.
So I got all four o's and I got a 3.8
which was like a major dig and the dig was
in, I think it was like in relation,
like I don't know what the word was,
but when I got debriefed on it,
what the guy that gave me the three
eight mm. What he, what he told me,
which I actually was proud of. Cause
that's how stupid I was. He's like, you,
you're, you're too hostile with
people that aren't squared away.
That's literally what he told
me. He figured it out and
I was all like, whatever,
you're damn right. Damn hostile towards
people that aren't squared away.
I'm going to go to war. Right.
Just an idiot. That's what,
that's what the situation
was. And you know,
it made me mad if a leader was weak
and I would form these antagonistic
relationships with leaders if
I thought that they were weak
and one of these bosses eventually that
I fought, I was better than [inaudible].
Right. I thought I was smarter,
thought I was smarter than him.
Right.
I thought that he was an idiot.
I should have his job right. How
often do you think that, right,
I should have that guy's job.
I'm, yeah, I'm smarter than them.
And the more I showed this attitude, the
worst our relationship got an a low end,
the less he listened to me and the less
influence I had over how we did things.
And therefore the, the worst
we did. And the end, the,
the worse.
Our ability to perform God because he
was just doing things the way he fought
without any good input from anyone
below him in the chain of command.
All because I had formed this
antagonistic relationship with them,
which was bad because then he's not
listening to me. And then one day,
one day,
I said to myself,
if I'm so smart,
if I'm such a smart guy,
why am I losing? Hmm?
Why am I losing?
Okay
if I'm so smart,
if I am so smart,
why can't I get this guy to
do what I want him to do?
Even though he's my boss?
It doesn't matter if I'm so smart,
much smarter than him. Why can't I get
him to do what I want them to do? Mm hmm.
Why?
If I'm so smart,
how come I can't have more influence over
the way we operate if I'm so smart and
he's so dumb.
And that's,
that's when I realized that
that's when I had an awakening,
an awakening that instead of
blaming him for being stupid,
I was the one who was being stupid.
I had lost the ability to influence
my boss because I was being stupid and
because of my ego,
I literally thought I deserved his job.
That'd be I fought pretty much anyone
could, should anyone in the staff his job.
And therefore,
since I thought that I,
I undermine him instead of supporting
him instead of building a relationship
with them, I undermined them. Now,
once I got humble
and I started to build a positive
relationship with them instead of an
antagonistic one, that started
to change. And because,
because then he started listening to me,
he started to change some things and
my influence over the whole situation
became better because I now had a
relationship despite the fact that I,
I like the guy.
Despite that fact,
I built the relationship and the situation
got better. I had more influence.
And that became kind of my standard
operating procedure was to build
relationships with people.
Even if I didn't like them,
to build relationships with people
so that I could have more influence.
Now does what does that sound like?
Right.
That sounds like I'm kind of this
manipulative to face, superficial,
disingenuous guy that's,
that's being devious and conniving.
Not keeping it real, not
keeping it real. Right,
but the fact is that is not
true. That's not, that's not,
that's not who I am.
You don't know who I am.
I'm a guy that's trying to accomplish
the mission. That's what I am.
I'm a guy that is trying
to accomplish the mission.
Who is putting my own ego in check to
build a relationship with someone that I
don't like, that I don't respect,
but what I'm trying to do is
improve our operational capability.
That's what's more important to me.
Trying to arrange the situation,
build the relationship so that we do
better. Not so that I get promoted,
not so that I'm getting some accolades,
but so that we as a team
do a better job.
Put the little feelings aside
because I want the team to win.
So if you're having, having some
trouble getting over your feelings
and getting over your ego to build
relationships for the good of the team,
ask yourself the same question
I asked myself a long time ago,
which is this,
if I am so smart,
why am I not winning?
And if you answer that question honestly,
then you'll put your ego in check.
You'll go build the relationships that
will make you and your team accomplished
the mission.
And when
there you go,
can't help but agree with that one.
You know what?
You know what's funny is when you think
about like why you wouldn't like someone,
what, what causes you to not
like someone? Most of the time,
that's your ego anyways. Most of the
time. That's your ego anyways. Yeah.
And, and so, you know,
you had that story of the,
you know, you were consulting
somebody. It was like a big seal,
like a Lacrosse guy.
That story is probably the
most common story. I mean,
the way you handle it different.
Yeah.
But that scenario that you started with
with Esther soul common men where yeah,
they rubbed you the wrong way because
right off the bat you see him as some kind
of competitive figure to
you. Like they're, you know,
some, you know, competitive,
you're competing with them in your
own mind in whatever, and few things,
probably mutual a lot of the time, you
know, so you guys don't like each other,
you know, one that, anything
he says you're, you know,
you're already defensive,
but it's weird man, how
you can, how that happened.
Like that's happened to me before as it
wasn't as overt, but just like, yeah,
I don't really feel that guy, you
know, I don't like I went because I,
not only is he like when you look at them,
whatever,
they're kind of competitive with you,
but maybe they do something just this
much different than you, you know,
like it just different in philosophy or
something like that. So I was like, oh,
I'm against that guy.
And then they open their mouth and say
one word to you and it's real nice.
You're like, Oh, I love that guy.
You know, just one little thing,
just one little like, hey, I'm cool.
You know, I like you kind of thing.
And it's like, oh man. Yeah. When they
say something humble to you, yeah.
It disarms your ego and you're
all of a sudden your bros. Yeah.
So weird how that is.
If they escalate the ego situation,
which then it's very
problematic cup until the time.
I mean really that's the natural course
of things cause you do have to put on
the brakes on your feelings and be like,
okay,
let's make a different kind of
decision than the automatic one.
I've got to switch to manual
real quick and then boom.
But the bottom line is you're going to
interact with all kinds of different
people. If you're in any kind of
team whatsoever, which is most,
most human beings interact with
other human beings through their job,
through their life, through, I mean you
can apply this to your family too, right?
There's someone in your family
that you don't get along with.
Well what good does it do?
Does it make your family unit better
when you let those emotions play out?
And let your ego play out. No,
it doesn't. You're better off.
You'll get further and
you'll have a better,
you'll have a better life in your family
if you put your ego in check and say,
you know what, I'm just going to
build a relationship with this person.
It's going to make everything better
and smoother. It's like, man, if he,
I feel like you can take the place of any
marriage counselor by just saying that
for real. Like all you gotta
do it and they got to do it,
but all you gotta do is ask like,
is this going to help the relationship
with my wife or my family, whoever it is,
and your,
is this going to help their relationship
if I do this or don't do this or is it
going to hurt it? And
that's it. That's it.
That's super general question
and whatever, but it's,
it's so cut and dry most of the time.
You know, of course there's exceptions,
but generally speaking it's pretty
cut and dry and be like, okay,
in a lot of time, just like I said, it
has to do with like your ego or your,
you know, this, this sense of vengeance,
little micro sense of vengeance
because I can't believe she doesn't
respect the fact that I took
out the trash, you know,
she asked me to take their trash all the
time. Finally, when I do it, nothing,
you know,
like tell him it's just that
I was talking to a friend of mine
and we were talking about you.
You know, I've talked about the
mutiny that I had the opportunity,
but we had a mutiny. We fight, we had a
mutiny against our, our platoon commander.
We fired,
he got fired.
And then the other guy that came in to
take his place was like the best guy.
And I was talking to a guy that worked
with him much later when he was a senior
senior guy and I was
telling him, I was like, oh,
when I talk on the podcast about the
platoon commander, that was like the best.
That's who I'm talking to. He's like,
no way. And, and this guy worked with,
he's a senior guy and he says, you
know, when he, when I worked with him,
he would take out,
he would take out the trash from the
office every day and he and I started
laughing. I'm like,
that's a, that's right.
And I'd be looking and he was saying
like, Oh, I look at him and be like, sir,
you don't, you don't need to do that. It's
like, no, no, no. It's all good. You know,
someone's got to take out the
trash. I got it. This is a seat.
A guy that shouldn't have been
taking out trash for 25 years,
taking out the trash. Was He picking
up breath and picking up brass,
taking out trash? That's,
that's being humble.
Being humble goes a long way.
Next year.
We've got time for one
more because I got stuffed
I,
I'm a veteran in graduate school.
My mother passed away in April
and it took a few weeks off.
While that was helpful,
I'm struggling returning to work my
peers or younger and inexperienced.
I'm the oldest and look in the cohort and
probably the first vet to come to this
Grad program have already had some
uphill battles and up to this point,
I truly believe I was worthy of
my own suffering. Now though,
after sobbing on a plane while listening
to episode one 22 I don't feel as
worthy. I wasn't there for my
mother when she died. In fact,
I cut her out due to her drinking,
which is what killed her.
I've lost people close to me
in the past and in the service,
but this is different. I know
one thing. I'm a fighter.
I've had to fight all my life to get
where I am, but I'm feeling deflated.
I mean, you start with, of
course you feel deflated
because you lost your mom.
That's,
that's normal.
But what is not normal and what you have
to fight against is staying deflated.
So I mean, listen,
you're mom is gone and you
should certainly mourn that
you weren't by her side
when she died.
And this is due to the fact that you had
to cut her off and you had to cut her
off because of her drinking.
If you don't cut someone off when
they're going down that path,
you're only enabling them.
And that is not the right thing to do.
Okay?
And of course
we want to be able to save
everyone that's absolutely,
we want to be able to save everyone,
especially our own family members.
But the fact of the matter is that you,
you just can't save everyone.
No one can,
no one can.
Addiction is
okay
in many cases,
stronger than us.
Stronger than anything.
Stronger than love, destroy,
believe it or not,
stronger than life itself.
Sometimes that's how strong addiction is
and you cannot and are not
expected to be able to defeat that.
Okay?
So you did what you could
and in the end the battle was lost,
not because of you,
but because of addiction
and it is hard to face that kind of loss.
But now
how are you going to look at this?
How are you going to deal with us?
I look at it like this.
Your mother,
your mother gave you a gift,
a precious gift
she gave you the gift of knowledge
took that knowledge,
allows you to see how destructive
that force of addiction can be.
You saw it destroy her.
You saw that addiction destroy
her because she showed it to you.
That was her last gift to you.
She,
she's actually given you life twice,
once at birth and once at her death.
She's actually shown you how to
live by showing you how not to live.
So
thank your mother for that.
Literally thank or literally go to her
grave side and get down on your knees and
say thank you to her
and then tell her that
you won't let her down
and then tell her that you
will learn from her lesson
and then tell her that you will
go on to live an incredible life,
a life that she would be proud of,
a life that she didn't have,
but a life
that she is making sure you can have.
Now you said
that you're a fighter and that's the one
thing you know is that you're a fighter.
Well now get out there
than fight
and you know that that question and kind
of thinking about the answer to that
question that got me thinking about an
article that I read about Anthony Bordain
and Anthony Bordain.
Obviously he was about as
successful as as anyone could be.
I mean he was a successful guy
in so many aspects and yet,
and yet he killed himself
and I didn't know him personally,
but you know,
he knew people that I know. You know
he was, he was friends with Joe Rogan.
He was, he was friends with Harley Flan.
Again, he was friends with guys that,
guys that have really good guys.
And so in that way I kind of felt like
I knew what kind of a guy who was at
least,
and even from the outside,
even without having any
connections to them at all,
he was the kind of guy that had
just about everything that, that,
that most people would want.
And even still, I mean,
obviously that wasn't enough.
Well,
in the article that I read,
there was a quote from one
of Anthony Bourdain's books,
and the book was called a cook's tour.
He said, in this book, I wanted
adventures.
I wanted to go up the known river to
the heart of darkness in Cambodia.
I wanted to ride out into a desert
on camelback sand and dunes in every
direction,
eat whole roasted lamb with my fingers.
I wanted to kick snow off my boots
in a Mafia nightclub in Russia.
I wanted to play with automatic
weapons in Phnom Penh,
recapture the past in a small
oyster village in France,
step into a CD,
neon lit,
pull Korea in rural Mexico.
I wanted to run roadblocks in the middle
of the night blowing past angry militia
with a handful of her old marble packs
experience, fear, excitement,
wonder. I wanted kicks.
The kind of mellow,
dramatic thrills and chills
I'd yearned for since childhood
kind of adventure I'd found as a
little boy in the pages of my tin,
tin comic books.
I wanted to see the world and I wanted
the world to be just like the movies.
That's what Anthony Bourdain said,
just like the movies.
But you know what?
To me
world is not like the movies.
The movies aren't real.
They don't exist,
but you do.
And life,
this life is,
it's better than any movie.
There is moves.
They're supposed to provoke emotion.
They're supposed to
make you feel something,
but I have a better idea.
Go out into the world
and actually feel it.
Go feel joy and love and triumph
and rapture and ecstasy and glory.
Go feel those things.
And you know with those feelings
there will be other feelings as well.
It'll be okay.
Sorrow and pain and
sadness and desolation and
suffering.
There'll be all those feelings too.
But you know what?
That's okay.
That's okay. Take both
sides. Feel all of it.
That's what life is. Those
feelings, those emotions,
those highs and those lows,
those are life
and those emotions and those feelings
are better than 80 movie because they are
real.
So make your own
comic book,
Make Your Life Your own movie bet.
Actually make it better than a movie.
Not,
not better because it's more adventurous
or more romantic or more mellow.
Dramatic. Make it better
because it's real.
It's real.
So it is better.
And you know what real
comes with some downsides.
You'll comes with some darkness.
Yeah,
but that's okay.
It's okay.
Because when you know the darkness,
the light becomes even brighter.
Yeah.
So go out there,
move toward the light,
move toward
the light
and live,
live.
And I think that's
all I've got
for tonight. So, so echo,
let's talk to people a little bit about
how support this podcast
and at the same time moved themselves
a little further away from the darkness
and a little bit closer
to the light
cause we make the podcast so everyone
can learn. And if you want to
support the podcast,
there are some really
good ways to do it and
that's the goal.
Sports podcasts,
and you're supporting yourself
at the same time. So we got,
they go hand in hand. Agree hundred
thousand percent not possible,
but we'll deal with it. Can you agree?
One thing, you know how they say,
I agree with you 110% I agree with you,
but I think I feel 10% even more strong
than what you just said. You know?
Okay. Technically that could be anyway.
Yes.
So we'll start with the
origin or gene USA in Maine,
Farmington, Maine, to be
exact American made products.
What do we got? Okay. Geese.
That's really the,
the flagship I liked the word flagship
flagship product is the Gif Main Ford.
You get to specifically
for Jujitsu in America,
also made for specifically Jujitsu but
usable for many different activities like
making a suit, rash guards. Oh
yeah. It's like flagship. Right.
Which I agree with. You also have
rash guards and other stuff. Stuff,
compression gear, compression
gear. Yeah. Spats, if you will.
A yet for sure.
But the gies aren't just like gies though.
See what I'm saying? They're not just
a general that guid made in America,
by the way,
for judges to specifically when you move
into Jujitsu is different than moving
in. I don't know, whatever else
you might wear a g in Veg, tennis,
whatever.
Bro.
You were saying you're going to make a
suit with the dragon is kind of crazy.
Yes. I have an idea of something
to make with the Dragon. We've,
I'm going to talk to Pete about, all
right. What does it lay it on me state.
He'd reveal. Reveal,
believe it or not. Boots.
Boots. Okay. Yeah. So they wouldn't
be full drag? No, no, no. They'd be,
they'd be very similar to the
old school Vietnam jungle boots,
but they'd have the dragon. We
instead of canvas, they'd have dragon.
We've and because,
which I think is the PR,
literally the perfect material for
the kids, the jungle. But old school,
jungle boots are part leather, leather,
like leather around the toe and the heel.
But then they have canvas on the sides.
And I,
I wore jungle and I still wear
jungle boots. I love junk.
So if we made,
because the cotton canvas
does stay wet longer,
but if we use the dragon, we've, it
dries quicker cause it's a blend.
But cotton is also very
comfortable to wear.
It allows circulation so many ways.
That's what, well, I'll talk to Pete,
we'll make it happen,
but it's still the,
the shorts that I have no one else can
have is dragging me for it. Yeah. Okay.
So let's talking to Pete about little,
I'll make some more and we went to the
thing and that's whole other thing.
But here's, here's what I
do remember. Get if you,
since you brought up boots where,
okay, so those shorts, you know,
I have kids and with kids comes messes.
We don't worry, they'll spill some,
I dunno, whatever. So stuff will
land on those shorts and you know,
the kind where it's like,
Dang,
I don't want to take off
the shirt and go wash them.
Like let me just put some water. But
then some of the messages, I can't,
you can't just put water and he goes away.
You got to scrub it.
But if they're like normal shorts,
I'm a scrub it with like a brush and it's
going to kind of mess up the shorts a
little bit right there,
you know?
It'll make it like kind of free it'll
frame or something like that. Brad,
now these ones for,
I'm scrubbing it with a steel wool
thing to get the thing out. Brad.
The thing is like new still aside from
like the cotton part feeds right? The,
you know how to blend and I told the
cotton ones will fade so it has this
awesome little gray striped
with black is Brett's dope.
Incidental dopeness improvement in the,
in the aesthetic look. That's a side
note, but I'm saying it's tough with it.
You see what I'm saying? So it kind of
makes sense now dragon, we boots, boom,
you're in the jungle fishing,
whatever else we're doing with them
and they handle, you know what I mean?
I'll work on it. Would you make it
like on the inside? Would it be,
what do you call it, water
proof or whatever. That's
the thing with jungle boots.
You don't want them waterproof.
They're brew.
They're highly review of little
islets. Oh yeah. Little drains.
So you want them highly breathable,
like, like not even breathable open.
Yeah,
there's holes.
It's purposely put in there so that this
concept is real Jujitsu ish. You know,
cause like on, I at first thought you'd
be like, Hey, you're gonna walk in water.
We need to fight that water. Allow the
water in it. It allowed the ladder out.
Yeah, man. That's good. That's good.
See Brad, that's why you're advanced.
See you think about these constraints.
Speaking of being
advanced and comfortable,
advanced comfort with the joggers
and the sweats. It's my experience.
Try for yourself. Many people, actually I
saw the guy today, maybe yesterday, today,
yesterday, I forget, but he
got the Hoodie, one of origins
Hoodie. Boom. Seconded.
That exact notion. Most comfortable
that he ever he's ever had.
That's a bold state and I could just see,
tell from his profile picture that he
knew about comfort. I Dunno. It just,
I just could feel it. Nonetheless.
It happened factually. Also,
we got some supplements up there
on the origin main.com website.
You can get some supplements and
supplements. Power. Some good ones. Yeah,
so joint warfare. That one.
What could we call that one?
A flagship supplement.
You could call every,
and I'm going to call it a flection in
the flagship is good man. Someone said,
someone said on social media, go back
to the old way you were doing this.
A porch sounds clunky.
Is it?
Get it back to echo. He said, you know
what? I said, couldn't take it anymore.
I'm going to be honest.
I will accept the possibility probability
of you not being the only one that
thought that I'm going to go with it.
That one guy though,
he was fired up enough to tweet
me and say, Bra sounds clunky.
Dang. I kind of appreciate
it. Your stove. I really do.
Now that we could have a separate podcast
where he could just do some horse the
whole time. Separate. Yeah.
Yeah. You can kind of choose,
choose your own supports maybe.
Nonetheless.
Now this is what we're doing and we're
going with joint with joint warfare.
Join Warfare,
right.
Good for your joints will make
it three is good for your joints,
and that's in Krill oil.
So you got joint where heard glucosomine,
conjoint and curcumin. That
helps you bring, by the way,
as we find out additionally,
then you got a job that Patrick,
Rhonda Patrick, right? Yeah,
I read that too by the way. It's
good. Uh, then you got, okay,
so you've got joint warfare. Boom,
come close to me and can drain.
That's what for I think cartilage, if
I'm not mistaken. Joints, all this stuff.
Boom. Pure cumin for some brains and
memory stuff. Boom. That's joint warfare.
Then you've got Jocko Super Krill. It's
where he joined. So make it threes.
And that's also for other
parts of your anatomy.
Staff will say your whole internal system.
You say Uris,
eyes, eyeballs, eyeballs, eyeballs,
Oregon's brains and you crack open a
Krill oil capsule and put it directly into
your eyes. Is that a good
thing? I'm assuming? No,
but yeah,
let's not do that.
Been on Krill oil for so long.
Yeah.
People like I don't want
to ever go off of it. Yeah,
I think that's a good idea
to never go off of it.
The reason is because I had a
guy many years ago that was a,
this is when I was probably 35.
Sure.
I met a guy that was 53,
I think,
and he was cured and he was jacked,
but he wasn't, he wasn't Jack like, uh,
like a, uh, big bodybuilder
juiced up guide, just Jack,
like totally athletic and in
really great shape. And I was like,
hey man, what's the deal with, you
know, and he's like, I take Krill oil.
That's easy. That's the
secret he's attributing. Yeah,
he attributed all of this.
Now. He was a competitive
power lifter at what time?
So he had maintained and
continued to work out.
But he was basically saying that
to me as if we already knew that.
But we already know that you got to Jack
Steele. Like we, that's a given. I'm just,
cause I was talking to him for awhile
and we were talking about lifting and
we're talking about this and, and
then finally, you know, I got to like,
cause what do you think it is?
And he's like, I take Krill oil.
This was before and I was
like, okay. Sometimes when
somebody tells you something,
you're just like,
you just look at the guy and when they
give that much weight to it, yeah.
It's like, okay, we're going with
that. And what's cool is that that's,
I definitely,
I definitely felt
the difference in my joints.
Yeah.
I don't know about my eyeballs, although
I don't wear glasses at this point. Yeah.
There it is. Proof of that. That's,
that's something, that's not nothing,
that's for sure. And the same way
you, you um, well not in the same way,
but slightly similar way. You had the
power lifter guy talk about Krill oil.
My father in law, as I've mentioned
before, told me about critical,
but way better than fish oil.
And you know, he's telling
me or what was he jacked?
He, here's the thing, he wasn't jacked
and here this is part of the whole story.
Which kid is going to kind of feed into
your point? No, he is not jacked at all.
In fact, Meniam go lift by. This guy
shouldn't even be in the same gym with me.
He should be in the democracy is going
to hear this podcast. I don't care.
Absolutely a hundred percent sure not
really doing a good job building that
relationship with the family at
the end of the day, Yo Yo feel,
see the moral and I think it will.
I think anyway, so no, not jack.
The answer is no. Um, he can
swim for ever, ever. In fact,
he goes into Hawaii,
me and Molly waters with the,
you know the web hands for swimming
body board. He's using them.
They're just west spongers. Yeah,
sure. He doesn't, you know, it's funny,
but he's a swimmer, so he'll just swim
hour, boom. Just swimming. Anyway.
He'd always say, you know, Krill oil, all
this stuff. But yeah, he's not jacked.
He didn't lift like why he could use
take Krill oil and you get your x, Y,
z results. Cool. I don't
want those x, Y, Z results.
Those results that you're essentially
benefiting from apparently aren't applied
to my goals. Chat on. Exactly right.
So I'm like, okay, cool. I get it.
Health nut. She's a health nut he sent
to health. That's a positive thing.
It's not bad. There's, there's
worse things to be a nut about.
I'll tell you that health is a good thing
anyway cause into health is a little
bit better to be out. But that's
true. I'm not going to disagree.
So you know, for years and I'm
like cool, good for the info. Yeah.
Then you come along and you're
like, yeah, Krill oil. Boom.
Next day I'm on the
Krill literally next day.
And so of course he's been saying
it the whole time or whatever,
but at the end of the day he's right.
He's absolutely right. He was right. Yeah.
So the moral of the story is
you could be right and not jack.
Yes. I got to kind of separate,
you know, my, what do you call,
I got to detach. This is
what I got it, you know,
like an older guy with the ability to do
the things and at the health level he's
at, I do want for myself regardless how
much weight I can lift, I can't lift.
That's what I want. That's
what challenge man. Big Time.
And here's the thing I didn't think
indirectly as well because the better your
joints feel, especially as you
get older, but just in life,
regardless how old you are,
the better your joints are functioning,
the more you're going to be able to lift
or move a mountain climb or right bike
or compete in back mitten, badminton.
How do you say that? Bad Mitt to,
okay. Yeah, competing that
that's true value. We all stiff.
We don't need tennis or badminton elbow,
you know,
for anyway Krill oil, that's the one
Omega threes and then you have discipline,
right? And that's where your
brain memory, how many things,
so they play into each other.
You see what I'm saying?
So the joint warfare has a
brain stuff and the joint stuff.
Krill oil has the joint stuff.
Really good day at Jujitsu the other day,
and I was talking to Dave Burke on my way
home from Jujitsu. Could deal, did. Yeah,
good deal Dave. And I was like, I was, you
know, he, you said only I trained today.
I was like, I had a really good day.
What does that mean? I'm like, oh,
I'll just means, you know, like
just getting after just, yeah,
and I realized that the past.
Anyways,
I realized that I've been taking
like three scoops of discipline.
Is that even legal? Yeah. Well, you
know, it could be. It should be.
Maybe. Yeah. Well,
depends on what you mean by fair because
if you're going in to compete with your
training partners, which you do from
time to time, let's face it then. Yeah,
it's a little bit of an advantage.
Fair. No, it's actually,
it's fair Andy or whoever you
go into train with Dean, me,
we could take three things that
discipline if you want it to, one or two.
If it's fair, it's fair. In
fact, I recommend take three
things, a discipline, boom.
There it is. This one,
cognitive enhancing, so they
all play with each other.
That's important.
Very important.
I think regardless of
how much you can lift,
check also Moke,
Moke what is small?
What is that?
Who is sold as just asking me about more.
And the best thing about when people
ask you what mark is, as you get it,
you get a chance to do the routine.
You get a chance to do the routine.
When someone's like,
I'll talk about what time
you get to do the routine, which is what's
milk? Oh, it's mark. That's the routine.
That's 13 well, what is it?
It's more, no, it's mold.
You want some kind of a
explanation? You're like, no,
no, it's, it's more, yeah.
Common sense really.
After you say that,
you just take common sense from there
and boom, clear. Yeah. That's my goal.
My goal is that it ends up in the
Oxford English dictionary, like Xerox.
And then if someone doesn't know what
it is, they can just go look it up.
I'll look it up in the dictionary.
By the way,
Google is Google in there for like,
all right,
go Google that. Well, yeah, so you
could go Google [inaudible]. Yeah, yeah.
It's there. You'll find it. Yes
sir. You will know what it is. Well,
you'll know that it's tasty,
but got it said, hey, I, I,
I don't use protein powders,
but does it taste that good?
So I should just get it anyways.
My answer was a hundred percent
run sounding. Absolutely.
You just want to have a really
good dessert. Give him milk.
Peanut butter's is common.
So Dave Burke is,
Dave Burk is on the path to uh,
to order all the food on the peanut butter
chocolate anyway, so the whole supply,
yeah, he wants all supply. Not a
bad idea. She had thought about,
if you didn't know, look, I'm going to
violate some terminologies scenarios here.
Mark is protein powder.
It's actually Moke GMN the best protein
powder that tastes like a dessert
straight up does though.
Not just claims and doesn't,
it does straight up literally a,
and we will have milk at the immersion
camp this summer up in Maine on Echo Lake
layers August 26 through September
2nd two sessions come up there.
I'll be there. Life will be there. Echo.
Charles will be there and apparently
you say you will be rolling, you know,
limited,
limited rolling from from which sounds
like predetermined excuses, which is fine.
Yeah. Well here. Okay. All
right, well let, let me lay
it out then playboy. Ah, the,
the gooey I'll be doing less of because
Ge has a lot more group grouping,
grouping, pulling, so pulling.
I'm really out of pulling.
I can't do bullying.
You're very limited maybe with one hand,
so I'll do geeky but it's like okay now
I'm rolling literally with one end by
the way will be there.
Yeah,
Dean lister will be there and if
you want to learn from someone,
he is one of the top people
in the world to learn from.
And I know that's a bold statement.
I know it is.
He's got a mind that understands not
only the mechanics and the concepts of
Jujitsu at an added,
but one of the highest levels of
anyone I've ever communicated with,
but also knows how to express
those concepts in a very clear way.
So immersion camp,
August 26 through September 2nd go and
come up there. We'll see you up there.
Good place there. And we will
have mock there. Yes, lots of it.
And Dean's good at at kind of taking
the concept and really clarifying the
concept even separate from
the action for sure. If,
I mean the mood is always attached but
dean says things sometimes that I run
over and take note, take like a
little, a little note on my uh,
on my phone and I call it, that's
a good one. And usually I say,
usually I'm thinking I'm going to, when
we, when he comes on the podcast, I'll,
I'm going to have him talk about those
things so we'll pick them up. Oh,
so good way to support is the fact we're
on top of the fact or as part of the
fact that Jocko has his own store.
It's called Jocko store.
Let's go to Jocko store.com for these
items. It's where you can get rash guards.
You can definitely get rash
guards. Yes. Get after it.
T shirts, a bunch of t shirts. Yeah. The
ones that say discipline equals freedom.
New Tee shirt coming. New t shirts
are coming. T shirts with Pearl.
Yeah. Oh Dang. Two of them if, yeah, if
you're just sitting in the tee shirts,
discipline equals freedom.
It's a good one. I get
revealed how deep the expression
discipline equals freedom goes like almost
Dayton. That not daily, but let's
you understand it at a deep level,
a deeper level presented to reveal
to you how important it is, how much,
even more than I previously thought
the week before. Yeah. Okay.
It's almost like it has no, no limit
to the layers. It's pretty important.
You don't actually,
I've been sporting this
one equals freedom hat,
the trucker hat
and I also have the deaf beanie.
Get some.
Yeah, that's a good one. So you've got
that those are available check. Yup. Um,
yes and also hoodies,
heavy hoodies and lighten hoodies. I
know, bro. I know and I, and I know,
but I haven't been getting uh,
feedback online and offline by the way,
for the light Hoodie.
They want the light Hoodie, man. They want
to represent. You know, like I said, Paul,
why I'm telling you there,
there are times maybe to Hawaii,
all of them, everybody and all the
Ohana and Hawaii is hitting you up.
The caught my eye enough and because
in Hawaii and other places here,
let's face it, there are
times where it's like, hey,
like yesterday was one of them. It's like,
Bro, it's kind of, it's kind of cold,
but it's not cold. It's kind of cool if
you wear a tee shirt, it's like, man,
this environment,
weather is
not feed mills go deaf
core, negative, negative.
Nope.
That's not to me,
especially if you're at like a
little gathering social situation,
maybe it could be looked at as paramount.
But here's what it is. If, if the,
if the weather,
whatever environment is offering
slight discomfort hard right now,
because everything you're saying is
things that I wouldn't allow myself or
anyone in my immediate family.
Just admit it doesn't make it,
it doesn't make it any more true.
That's the thing. So Hey, look at me.
You were cruising right outside. Maybe
not you. I mean, I don't think you do.
I don't think you do. That's the
thing. If me and Dave worked for that,
maybe he'd want them and yet it's
maybe three degrees too cold.
Yeah, you can suck it up. But what,
why you got to endure discomfort
at times when it's not necessary.
Unless you're exercising your tolerance
for discomfort. You shouldn't be,
which you should add all point at all
times. That's what you're saying. Okay.
Me and date of birth,
we don't agree with this.
So you put on a regular hoodie or heavy
or even a medium Hoodie after what?
Five minutes? Six minutes. We worked
out earlier today. Whatever that he,
it's too hot. So thick Hoodie,
too hot. No hoodie to Colt.
Boom. Light Hoodie. Perfect. Because you
didn't know about that. Perfection. Uh,
dichotomy. Men, you know the zone balanced
the zones. Okay. Anyway, light Hoodie.
Discipline equals freedom.
That's the freedom part. Boom.
How about that women's stuff as well,
by the way,
women's tee shirts
specifically for the ladies
and tank tops. Boom. Rash guards
are kind of for everybody. So boom,
you can also subscribe to this podcast
on Itunes, Google play, stitcher,
leave reviews.
So I can read them and laugh because you
guys are really good at writing a good
code reviews that cracked me up, so
thank you for that. Stitchers won't,
by the way, don't forget about the
youtube. You can subscribe to Youtube too,
and that's where you'll see echo
Charles is videos. Sure. That's,
we'll say you've got some skills in life.
That's one of your Paramount's
skills. Making cool videos. Cool.
Agree or disagree? Yeah.
Oh sure. That's not good.
I'm putting you on the spot to not
be humble, so I wouldn't do that.
Echo makes good videos and they're on
youtube and you subscribe to the channel
toggles podcasts, youtube
channel. Okay, well there you go.
Very easy to find for basic,
very subscribe bubble anyway.
Yeah,
good way to support for sure. Also
some excerpts on there. You know,
little lessons from this podcast directly.
And so sometimes you
don't want to listen to,
let's say you listen to podcast
number 101 and you're like, hey,
there's some good stuff in there, but
should I listen to the whole, you know,
however many hours of the podcast for
that one lesson that I want to kind of
revisit? Should you do that? Hmm. Some
of us don't have that kind of time,
so I'm going to put out some excerpts
from all the podcasts, most of them.
So you go on there, subscribe and get
a little alert when we put one up,
if that's the one you want to
listen to, boom, listened to it.
Good way to support too,
by the way. Also on it,
on it.com/chocolate this is
where I get all my kettle bells.
I won't say all my socks, but a lot of
socks. That's where I get them from.
I know it sounds weird, but
man, it's one of those things.
Sometimes you appreciate
the socks you're wearing,
especially when you're going
through the airport. Tsa, boom,
you gotta take off your shoes. Boom.
Hit them with the Onnit socks. Anyway,
fitness gear mainly. I think
that's, that's what I go
and for the information too,
by the way, like kettle bells, when I
started kettlebells, I heard good things.
You know I started the kettle bells.
They're kind of, they're intimidating.
So boom,
going on it.com they have all the info
on their little things about form little
workouts. Really good. Good on Macy's too.
Are they called battle Macy's?
Just Macy's.
They're steel sticks,
clubs,
clubs that look like, you
know the juggling clubs but
they haven't stayed there.
You can't juggle them. That's the thing.
If you could juggle those you'd be,
you'd be a complete bad ass juggle. Those
20 pounders, they're freaking heavy.
Yeah. And they're heavier than
they sound. When you say 20 pounds,
they're heavy. The only way they're
20 pounds, only way they're even,
they can even justify saying 20 pounds
is when you actually put them on the
scale and the number it happened cause
it says 20 otherwise it's not 20 things.
They were not made out of metal, but some,
you know, something from outer space.
If you brought him to the airport
and you know when you're checking in,
you know and you put the your luggage on
the scale and you know you were pushing
it, you know that it may be over 50
pounds and you're like nervous, right,
and then it doesn't hit 50 bucks.
If you've got that,
Macy had that Mason your hand,
you're about to put that on the scale.
You know this is going over.
I'm paying that extra overage fee.
That's what it feels like. I'm sorry.
As far as the mace goes anyway,
it happens to be a good thing to work
out with, but you grabbed that thing.
You'd be like, okay, what kind
of workout? I'm going to do this.
Boom on it.com/chocolate look
up the workout. You got it.
Also psychological warfare.
It's an album that has various
tracks on it that you can
play to push you through
moments of weakness and we are,
we are formulating psychological
warfare to all your excuses are lies.
Yes, it will work your working
title, working title, working title,
but it's pretty good title. Also
Jocko white tea. Here's the thing.
I'm a tea drinker. No, I don't know if you
know that. I'm a tea drinker right now.
I drink tea regularly. I think that's
kind of all it takes really. But
there was a whole thing I didn't realize,
I didn't know that tea drinker had like
some stereotypical thing behind it.
So when I came schema white teeth
people are like, oh that's really weird.
But you'd make tea cause they think I'd,
I'd be making what else Malki yeah they
think I'd make more but they wouldn't
think of you don't strike me as a teacher.
I didn't realize that.
So I guess we're changing the paradigm
and those stereotypes come will not be
expected and accepted anymore.
Agree. I drink tea and I'm proud.
Maybe you're changing,
you're just evolving.
The stereotype may because
you are a tea drinker.
I'll straight up and
drinking tea since day.
Not really since day one but since
I figured out what the day to day.
There you go. Boom. Yeah. So
Jocko White Tea, pomegranate,
all organic certified by the way,
cause you know Jock,
who cares about that kind of stuff in
the bags and in the camp. Big Deal.
I most tea drinkers care about certified
organic I think. Yeah, like it.
Well that's another stereotype.
So Gmo tea, no good. No good.
Will Not put that in my body. The
temple. Yeah, you're right. I agree.
You get on Amazon and in fact I think
that's the only place you can get it.
Well it is the only place you get
it right now. And important fact,
there's dry white tea that you put in
a brew and then there's the new thing,
which is an a can.
Yeah.
That's the one thing that's fired up
right now is people that are replacing the
12 are not the 12th but they're
replacing the four energy drinks,
which actually gives you no energy that
actually SAP your energy and crush your
soul and turn you into a health disaster.
People are replacing that crap
with Jocko white tea. Yeah.
In a can. One day it's going to be
everywhere. That's my suspicion.
You're just going to be and
people will just be, well,
you know the little Jocko white tea
on, you know, speaking of Oh yeah.
And also available in Canada.
I know a lot of Canadian folks say,
witness this stuff. Why can't I get up
here? So it's now available Amazon Canada.
I'm going to put it on the
store too. Okay. And I've
been working on it, you know,
and we're almost there. So check
back with the store Taco store. Okay.
That's a good place to happen.
They can get the t wherever.
I don't care if you're in wafer
for chocolate products are sold.
That's where they're sold.
Uh, speaking of Amazon books,
I got some books. Good. Yeah. One,
two are called the way of the word
kit where the worry kid from wimpy to
warrior, right? That's the, what do
you call it after the colon? That part,
that's the subtitle. Escher.
There it is. Wouldn't be to work.
And then the second one is Mark's mission.
Really clever evolution of
problems to be solved in both.
So now you have the ethos.
Okay. So, hi, I did it.
Do it is I read the first one and I
just keep repeating to my kids kids,
five, my daughter, oldest
five before bedtime,
boom and then repeating now
got two in the rotation. Boom,
so you can the chronological,
right, boom. It is good.
Very clever.
Very on.
What do you call it when
you assume something about
somebody and it reveals that
there's more to this person. Oh,
so you assumed I was capable.
Very incapable, but
yeah, that's a good one.
Also the discipline equals freedom field.
Manual field manual.
Best kind of manual in my opinion,
but this is like a manual for life.
I think it's like a ray basic
backbone for life. It is. Start there.
You'll be cubic solid.
I'm always stoked when I meet someone
that's comes up and it's like,
yeah, I'm on the path and like they're
not kidding. They're on the path.
Yeah. Crack that thing
open. Read two pages. Yeah.
Read two pages to prep
mentally for the day.
It will have impact and if you want to
listen to those pages is not available on
audible. It's available
on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play as an MP, three album with
tracks. That's where you can get it.
Of course you can also get extreme
ownership, extreme ownership,
but you can get the the the hardcover book
[inaudible]
and you can also get the auto.
That one you can get the audible version
and the audible version is Lafe and I
reading
that book,
that's who's reading it, that's who's
doing the narration. And then also Lafe
and I have a book called
the dichotomy of leadership,
which I talk about dichotomy
all the time on this podcast.
The reason I talk about is cause it's
hard to, I won't even say master,
it's hard to even get a
grip on that dichotomy,
the different dichotomies
inside of leadership.
And so Lafe and I knew that we had
to go into a more granular level of
explanation of the dichotomy of leadership
and that's what this new book is.
It comes out September 25th and also
for Leadership Training live inside your
organization,
whatever that organization might be.
Check out my company Ashkelon
Front leadership consulting.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's that.
We have one more muster in 2018 the
muster is a leadership conference.
We have one more in 2018
it is in San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th October 17th and
18th all the other ones that we've done
have sold out.
If you want to come get your ticket,
you can get an extreme ownership.com and
also for current uniformed personnel.
So people in the military, law
enforcement, border patrol,
firefighters, paramedics,
first responders,
we have roll call number one
September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
That's also,
you can also register for that extreme
ownership.com that's one day focused on
the dynamic leadership environment.
So it's like a muster more focused
on the issues of first responders.
Essentially functional. It's
luster, it's a mustard shorter,
it's a shorter muster,
it's more focused,
it's a cheaper price point and
it's one day. There's less,
uh, amenities, right? So
when you come to the muster,
everything's kind of kind of decked out
like the, the lunch meals. Really good.
The danger is great. It's like decked
out. It's taken to the highest level.
The, the roll call is like, Hey,
we're here to get the information
out to people that need it.
People that are in the field every day,
whether it's in the military,
whether it's on the beat as a cop,
whether it's a firefighter, you know,
for people that are on the job,
people in uniform that we try and support,
they need this leadership training.
They asked for this leadership training.
We needed to do it at
a cheaper price point.
Where can we save money and still get
it done. There you go. That's what the,
that's what the roll call is,
but it's the same deal as far
as as an old backstage. Oh No.
The game talking to everybody the whole
day. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'll be there.
No Green Room.
Okay.
And until we do see you
big time at either the muster or the
roll call or the immersion camp in Maine,
if you want to roll with us virtually,
we are all up on the interwebs on
Twitter and Instagram and dodge faci
echo was that equity Carlson.
I am at jockowillink and to those of you
in uniform that wear the cloth of the
nation without you,
this podcast and our
freedom would not exist.
So thank you to police, law
enforcement, firefighters, paramedics,
border patrol,
other first responders.
Thank you for keeping
us safe while we sleep
and also to those in uniform.
Thanks to your families
for their sacrifice.
That is a hard job as well.
And to everyone else,
thanks for listening.
Thanks for supporting.
Thanks for moving away from the
darkness and toward the light.
Thanks for fighting. Thanks for
getting after it. And most of all,
thanks for living.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko,
how.